Gregg Allman has died he was 69  [Music]  a statement on the musicians website  confirmed the news on Saturday that read  in part Gregg quote passed away  peacefully at his home in Savannah  Georgia and that he'd struggled with  health issues over the past several  years to sweet Melissa  Gregg helped found the Allman Brothers  Band along with his brother Dwayne in  the late 60s and was most famously known  for the hits Midnight Rider Melissa and  whipping post celebrities reacted to the  loss on social media share almonds  ex-wife and mother of their son Elijah  blue took to Twitter to remember the  late singer posting old photos of the  pair writing I've tried words are  impossible Melissa Etheridge posted this  throwback he showed me his tattoos his  voice his soul Keith Urban wrote my  heart breaks today at the passing of  soul brother Greg Allman